back this news is big and delicious the
buffet at win las vegas has announced an
expansion of their daily operations
becoming one of the first buffets on the
strip to fully open here to tell us more
is executive chef jason durante welcome
to the show buddy thank you very much
for having uh how many dishes do you
guys have at the buffet we have over 400
different dishes
have you tried them all yes i have have
you really yes i have every single one
do you have to taste them do you have a
favorite
oh wow uh i love our beef steamed chips
i absolutely love our lobster eggs
benedict they are absolutely delicious
our french toast are out of this world
our crepes are amazing everything is
amazing
how many different styles of cuisine do
you offer right now we have over 15
different styles we have latin we have
italian we have filipino we have all
over all over the map now you're back to
regular full operations what does it
mean open monday through monday through
sunday so the great thing is we're going
to be open seven days a week we'll be
open from eight a.m to nine pm so please
come on down and enjoy our food now you
have uh how does it work is it buffet
it's a single price endless supply of
food how does it work with drinks are
there endless drinks that you guys offer
absolutely we have a wonderful package
29.99 endless pour you can have sangrias
you can have champagnes and steam like
that we're actually offering over the
summer we have a full two and a quarter
pound lobster that we're going to be
offering to guests it's a 125 dollars
you have a full lobster it actually
comes just like this with all the
all the sides right there plus you also
get a vip pass to come into the vip line
and you also get a complimentary glass
of champagne as well too all for 125
dollars you can't beat that it looks
stunning you're gonna make something for
us today
we have our seafood paella that we
currently are serving and it's going to
be serving all throughout the whole
summer so right now we're just
everything's nice and hot and fresh as
you're making this more questions as
you're making this do you guys have
vegan options at the buffet we have many
vegan options we actually have a pancake
station that we offer vegan pancakes we
also do tacos that are made to order and
we have impossible meat that we can also
do a vegan taco as well you cover all
bases at the buffet absolutely i love it
gluten-free as well
all all of them okay we have the we have
the rice there what's going on we have
the rice here and right now we have our
beautiful seafood mix we have clams we
have mussels we have scallops how long
is something like this does this is this
steaming is are you making this in the
pot
this will probably last about five to
ten minutes on the buffet line isn't it
we're constantly we are constantly
changing fresh food all the time and as
we're making the seafood out here talk
about some of your fresh meats too that
you guys offer oh we have a 75 pound
beef steam ship that is cooked for 10
hours and then we put chimichurri on the
outside we have a beautiful pork loin we
have different types of meats out there
sausages we're also going to have
tri-tip probably over the summer again
so we have a lot of different stuff
coming up i got less than 30 seconds
with more seasoning here and we're going
to do a little taste so right now we're
going to do all this right here we're
going to throw some peas on here some
veggies we're going to throw some
roasted red peppers around the outside
and the coloring too i love the color
absolutely you need that coloration and
then a little bit of
and also to make sure you follow some
social media so we're done we're going
to show everything can i just dig in
here please help yourself
number one right here get into this
thing
10 seconds here
wow
are you kidding me with this no i'm
getting out of here this is so good oh
my gosh excellent well thank you very
much that is spectacular thank you so
much absolutely appreciate it chef james
my pleasure julian i'm gonna send it
over to you on youtube
i don't think we're gonna see